there are signs of biodiversity
all around this riverside in derbyshire
where once they milled cotton
nature has found its way back
but across the country experts say
there's nowhere near enough variety of
plant and animal life
we all think that biodiversity is fairly
easy to find but new research suggests
that the uk's industrial past has made
it one of the most nature depleted
countries in the world
the uk has an average of only 53 per
cent of its biodiversity left following
the industrial revolution well below the
global average of 75 percent
but experts say a 90 average of
biodiversity is needed to prevent the
world tipping into an ecological
recession an ecological recession is
where we've lost enough biodiversity for
a system to be really susceptible to
shocks and that includes things like
droughts and floods where the system is
going to struggle to recover from those
shocks but an ecological recession is
also likely to lead to greater outbreaks
of human diseases as well as pest
outbreaks
in gloucestershire just minutes from
stroud's town centre volunteers have
worked hard to restore habitats
well we've had
centuries of destroying biodiversity
for our own gain we want the the wood
or the water the raw materials but in
not valuing living nature we've been
missing a rather obvious
point
that our very well-being our existence
depends on nature
and if we construct an industrial
society that depends on destroying
nature at some point
we'll go too far
all efforts to reverse the industrial
impact of the past can have obvious
benefits but experts warned that so much
more will need to be done globally
to prevent an ecological meltdown
lisa dowd sky news